[Music]
hi my name is Christopher qua and I'm a
research scientist at MIT and I thought
it would be fun to tell you something
that I'm excited about and so that's you
know why I wanted to share it with you
so basically we're going to talk about
recurrent neural networks in brains and
machines um so how does this approach
work well I'm a neuroscientist so I want
to understand the brain and generally
that means I have some experimental data
that I start with uh for example this
could be neural data collected from
electrodes or behavioral data from
humans or animals performing a task um
but there's always gaps in this data you
know there's never quite as much um as
I'd like so what we're going to do is
we're going to supplement the study of
this experimentally collected data with
the study of artificial neural networks
that we've trained to perform the same
tasks that we're studying in the lab
okay so how does this work well we're
going to train recurrent neural networks
to mimic the behavior of humans U
monkeys mice or other animals performing
the experimental tasks that we're
interested in so the inputs to the RNN
are going to be time bearing signals
representing sensory stimuli and we
adjust the parameters of the RNN so its
time bearing outputs are the desired
Behavioral
responses now the way that we're going
to get this neural network to perform
the task is by adjusting all of these
black lines that you see in that figure
so these are the connection weights
between units in the network so one unit
could inhibit another unit in which case
the weight would be negative or it could
excite another unit in which case the
weight would be positive or two units
might not be connected in which case the
weight is zero okay so what do we get
out of training neural networks to
perform these experimental tasks well
interest interestingly one of the things
that we sometimes get is activity in
these neural networks that looks similar
to neural activity in the brain and
here's an example from motor cortex so
in this task a monkey had to touch and
hold his finger at an initial Target
location on a screen um until a goq
instructed him to reach to another
Target and this is without hitting any
of the barriers on the
screen there are different ways uh that
we could model this task with the neural
network but I to show you a simple
approach that's commonly used so the
inputs in this real experiment are
visual stimuli on a computer screen but
the inputs to our model are going to be
little one-dimensional bumps that
replicate the logic but not necessarily
the details of what the monkey is seeing
and we'll see later why this might be a
reasonable place for researchers to
start their modeling
efforts so in this experiment there were
27 different reach conditions so so
there's going to be an input bump that
specifies which one of the 27 different
reaches the model Network should perform
and then there's a goq input that tells
the network when to initiate the reach
and the output we'd like the network to
produce is the electrical activity
recorded from Seven mus muscles in the
monkey's arm as he was performing this
reaching movement so here we can see the
inputs and outputs uh for one of these
reaching movements and then here are the
inputs and outputs for another reach
okay and now we've got to the reason uh
why I wanted to walk through this
example so if you look at the activity
of single units in the model they look
approximately like single neurons
recorded from motor cortex so here are
the firing rates of a neuron recorded
for each of those 27 different reach
conditions and then here's the activity
from one of the units in the model okay
and then here are a few more
comparisons so the interesting thing
thing is that in spite of our model not
having realistic inputs and only
partially realistic outputs were able to
reproduce the fire rate dynamics of real
neurons and this similarity is
especially interesting because the
neural network wasn't constrained to
replicate neural data during training uh
the artificial RNN was only told really
what to do but not how it should be done
and then after we have a neural network
like this we can then use it to generate
hypo hes you know at least at the level
of these firing rates that we're looking
at about all aspects of the task okay so
at this point you know we could go into
more similarities between these firing
rates uh and really uh try to start to
pick apart this circuit and see how it
works um and this is actually a really
interesting thing to do uh in fact you
know there's some great work that's been
done along these lines um by I would say
you know many researchers um and this is
for diverse set of tasks and brain
regions um but what I want to get to Now
is really another big question um so
we've been looking at firing rates but
what I want to ask now is can artificial
neural networks teach us about more than
just neural firing rates so what I want
to know is if the connectivity of a
neural network is unconstrained and
optimized can we recover you know
something about the actual circuitry
used by the brain in other words can
artificial neural networks only teach us
about firing rates um or remember all
those connections that I talked about uh
that we adjust you know maybe they can
also teach us something about the actual
circuitry that gave rise to those firing
rates you know at least in some simple
cases so this is uh what I want to
explore the emergence of both neural
activity and connectivity by optimizing
recurrent neural networks so here's the
game plan um to tackle this question so
we're g to pick a task where we know
something about the brain's wiring
diagram and neural activity we're going
to create an artificial neural network
to solve the task and then we're going
to see if we match neural activity and
recover the ground truth
connectivity all right so there's just
not that many areas in the brain where
the connectivity is known at least at
this point in time but one of those
happens to be in the fly so the fly has
a collection of neurons in its brain
shown here that keeps track of its
angular orientation from 0 to 300 60° so
when a bump of activity is at this
location the fly thinks it's oriented at
say 0 degrees and then when the bump of
activity moves over here the fly thinks
it's oriented at 180
degrees now in addition to this compass
that stores the bump of activity there
are really two other main ingredients to
this circuit so the fly needs to be able
to move the bump clockwise and then move
the bump
counterclockwise so here's a schematic
IC of that circuit so the compass
neurons they store the angular
information from 0 to
360° and then a population of neurons
shifts the bump either clockwise or
counterclockwise so this is the circuit
that we're going to try and get we're
going to start off with a randomly
connected neural network and then see if
Network training will develop these
three populations the compass neurons
the clockwise shifters and these
counterclockwise
shifters all right now to mimic a fly
keeping track of its orientation the
neural network is going to have two
inputs so one input specifies the
initial head Direction This is the
initial angle that the fly is facing and
then the other input specifies the
angular velocity that changes over time
and the goal of this neural network is
to just integrate this angular velocity
um and then output its current head
Direction so this curve is one example
output from a network after it's learned
the task all right and now that we have
our Network let's start by comparing the
individual units in this network to
neurons in the
brain all right so here's the activity
of each unit uh plotted as a heat map so
yellow is high firing and dark blue is
no firing and we can see the head
Direction along the x-axis and then the
angular velocity along the Y AIS okay
now it's easy to see that some of these
units like these ones I just highlight
Ed you know they don't really care about
angular velocity they just sort of fire
strongly for a particular head direction
as if they're responsible for
remembering this particular
orientation and then there's another
group of units that are selected for
positive angular velocities and then
finally there's a third group of units
that are selected for negative angular
velocities and you know interestingly
these three groups of neurons are
consistent uh with the previous
experimental literature um in in fly and
rodent brains so I should just mention
you know that I'm showing you the tuning
curves for these putative you know
Compass units clockwise shifter units
and counterclockwise shifter units but
the real proof that these names have
some meaning is if you do some sort of
ablation or perturbation experiments on
the network you know see if they're sort
of causally involved in in these roles
and I'll show show you some of those
experiments in just a couple slides Okay
so we've we published um these results
in the paper we show more comparisons
between the firing rates of the
artificial and then the real neurons um
but for the sake of presentation we'll
just move on and sort of say okay now
that they look you know the firing rates
look reasonable let's look at the
connectivity in the
network so a useful way of looking at
the connectivity is to plot the
connection strength between units as a
function of how different their
preferred head directions are okay so
here for example are three units with
the activity plotted as a heat map this
is just like you've seen before and then
here's the same activity of these three
units plotted as a function of head
Direction and with the preferred head
direction for each unit marked by a DOT
okay so now we can plot the preferred
head direction for each of these Compass
units for example around a circle like
this and ask you know what's the
connection strength between units that
are close together you know are far
apart in this space and we can do the
same thing uh for the clockwise and
counterclockwise shifter units and now
importantly if we look at the connection
weights between these three populations
in the network we see some interesting
parallels to biology okay so let's look
at the
connectivity on the left is the raw
connectivity Matrix showing connections
between all units with the color
indicating the connection strength and
on the right is the average connectivity
obtained from this Matrix Plus plotted
as a function of the difference and
preferred head Direction just like we
were talking about okay so there's a lot
of structure between all the units here
but I just want to point out two things
uh that were surprising to me okay so if
we look at the connectivity between
units on the compass there's this sort
of local excitation long range
inhibition okay and it's kind of amazing
to me that the network went from
initially being randomly connected it
didn't know anything about you know
anything in the world right and then
over the course of training it learned
this really structured Solution that's
been proposed in previous theoretical
models and which is also seen
functionally in the fly okay and now if
we look at the connections from the
shifters to the compass units notice
that they're asymmetric with the shifter
population sort of exciting the next
bump location on the compass and again
this is something that's consistent with
experimental work although these Conn
are still being mapped out in more
detail and also the shifter population
in this model is sort of cleaning up the
old bump location with inhibition so
it's going to be interesting to see if
functionally this turns out to be true
in the fly um and now I'd like to show
you uh some ablation experiments we've
done uh snipping various Connections in
the network and part of the reason I'm
showing you this is just to get you
thinking more about different ways these
networks can be probed um you know it's
sort of an in place to be when you have
the ability to manipulate and record
from every single neuron in the network
and you also know and can manipulate
every single synaptic connection so
here's the network outputting a constant
angle so the angular velocity input is
zero and the network just needs to store
a single angle namely 180 degrees so on
the right we can see the activity of
each unit in the network visualized as a
heat map and like we might expect
there's a bump of activity on the
compass and then the shifter units are
not as active Okay and now let's start
removing some of the connections in the
network so the top row here is just the
same as on the previous slide and in all
of the subsequent rows we're going to
remove various Connections in the
network so we're going to start removing
connections at time step 75 and then
reattach them at time step
25 all right so the the second row shows
what happens when we remove connections
from all the compass units to all the
other units and from that little Heat
map you can see that the bump location
spreads out at least until we reattach
the connections and then the bump
stabilizes again and you know something
similar was done uh by the Genelia folks
in a recent neuron paper by Daniel
Turner Evans so they blocked all
connections from the compass neurons so
this would be Compass to Compass and
Compass to other neurons and this caused
the bump to disappear although the
compass was still active in this
non-coordinated way all right so now we
can sort of continue our Legion journey
through this little Network um and as
far as I know no one's conducted this
next leion experiment but I think it's
sort of an interesting prediction of
this model so the third row here shows
what happens when we remove connections
from the clockwise shifters to all the
units so the bump is still maintained
but it drifts in this counterclockwise
Direction and then the fourth row shows
what happens when we remove connections
from the counterclockwise shifters to
all the units and again the bump is
still maintained but now drifts in the
opposite direction so it drifts in this
clockwise Direction and then finally
this bottom row shows what happens when
we remove connections from both these
clockwise and counterclockwise shifters
to all the units so now the bump more or
less stays put okay so to sort of
summarize what's going on here um all of
these results are consistent with this
interpretation where even when the
network just needs to store a constant
head Direction both these clockwise and
counterclockwise shifters are sort of
simultaneously activate the compass with
these mutually cancelling signals okay
all right so now we can play the same
game with a shifting head
Direction so let's look at the panel of
figures at the top here so the top row
shows a constant counterclockwise
rotation and the bottom row shows a
constant clockwise rotation and the
black line is the target output of the
RNN if it's shifting correctly and then
the dash Red Line shows the actual RNN
output and you know we can see that
they're they're right on top of each
other so the network can keep track of a
shifting head Direction you know it's
doing what it should and now the second
set of figures this op q&r shows what
happens when we remove the connections
from the clockwise shifters to all the
units so in this case the network can no
longer shift the bump clockwise but it
can still shift the bump
counterclockwise so this really confirms
the accuracy of those labels we were
using you know we labeled the units
based on their tuning properties earlier
but now we see that sort of functionally
they're doing what we expect and this
next set of figures at the bottom shows
what happens when we remove the
connections from the counterclockwise
shifters to all the units so again you
know the network does what we would
expect um in figure s uh the network is
getting this angular velocity input
that's telling us to shift the bump
counterclockwise but it can no longer do
this when the counterclockwise shifter
units aren't connected to the rest of
the network however the network can
still shift the clockwise as shown in
figure U there so I guess you know kind
of the final take-home message is really
that the units are kind of functionally
segregated you know and that's something
that we can now see with all of these
lesion experiments you know each time we
leion we get a very distinct functional
effect so the network you know just over
the course of training has separated
into these modular components and you
know I just want to wrap up this story
by mentioning an interesting prediction
of this model so if the movement
statistics were changed during training
so this is basically you know how the
little uh simulated fly is kind of
rotating around uh this changes the
tuning properties of the model so one
prediction might be that if flies are
raised with different movement
statistics they'll develop neurons with
different tuning properties like this
shown in the figure and you know this
could also apply to different species
like flies and Locus that have different
movement statistics more naturally and
it'll be sort of interesting to see if
these predictions hold up in future
experiments
so uh summary you know for this little
project is that you know neural networks
have been used to model neural activity
in the brain um however this approach
has not been shown to recover both the
neural activity and the anatomical
properties of neural circuits and using
the head Direction system here as an
example we wanted to just push this
approach forward and show that these
artificial neural networks can be used
to study the brain at the level of both
neural activity and Anatomy um at least
at least in this simple example so
thanks to my collaborators on this
project Peter Matthew and shushan
way I want to highlight one more example
where I felt like rnns were helpful in
my research uh with just you know a
short one slide vignette here so in a
recent project we analyzed four
different data sets from monkeys
performing tasks having to do with
working memory and encoding timing
information and we found some
commonalities in the neural data of all
these data sets that we analyzed and we
wanted to conclude that the Dynamics we
observed were sufficient to solve the
task you know but but maybe our
conclusions were neglecting you know
some completely unknown computation that
just hadn't been recorded in the neural
data that we had and you know maybe this
was really necessary for solving those
tasks and this is one of the places
where rnn's played a role so the RNN
allowed us to study by Design the
complete set of task Dynamics something
we would not be able to do with only the
data that we had so these RNs were
important because they allowed us to
conclude that the dynamical features
that we observed in the data were
actually sufficient for solving the
tasks we considered um I'm not going to
go into details about this project but
if you're interested in those details
you can see the published
paper all right so now let's let's take
a step back here so these projects and
you know many other good ones like them
you know really drill down into the
specific
of a few behaviors and brain regions but
there's perhaps something more that we
might want on our journey to understand
the brain um you know we really need to
start trying to put our understanding of
these individual brain regions and tasks
together and this thought really
motivates the big goal for what I'm
going to tell you about next which is
whole brain simulations for cognitive
Neuroscience um you know really
ultimately if we want to understand the
brain we'll need to work towards these
whole brain simulations okay so two
immediate questions come to mind you
know why do this and then how are we
going to do this all right so let's
start with
why now we could all come up uh with
different motivations but one of the
motivations for me is that the kinds of
complex behaviors that I want to
understand really require the
interactions between different brain
regions so almost any task that we can
think of you know requires multiple
interacting brain systems you know for
example right now you're using your
auditory system your visual system your
motor system cognition memory the whole
thing and you know we need to work
towards models that can be used to
explain multiple brain systems and
multiple behaviors you know we need to
see if the lessons that we've learned
from each of these individual tasks and
brain regions can be productively
combined okay so why work uh towards
these multiple uh system brain models
well you know ultimately cognition is
distributed across many areas cognition
is flexible the brain can solve many
tasks uh different data sets are
different facets of the same system the
brain so you know ultimately there
should be some unifying explanation
behind it all um what would we really
want at the end of the day out of models
like this um well we'd want multiple
systems uh we might also want multiple
learning rules um acting on different
parts of the models perhaps different
brain regions that these models are
describing and then we'd also uh like
models that are useful for explaining
and making predictions about multiple
tasks and data
sets Okay but you know there's a problem
here that there's just there's a huge
design space so you know what kind of
signals are we going to use to navigate
through this and make any
progress we've been inspired uh by
efforts at modeling the visual system
where they have really clear benchmarks
and methods for evaluating different
models have led to advances in the field
and you know I'm thinking of benchmarks
um like image net for computer vision
and then more recently brain score from
comparing models of the visual hierarchy
to neural data um here's an example from
uh Dan Yaman haong and Jim De Carlo
where they showed that networks with
higher task performance can better
explain neural data um and what's
interesting for me is not just the score
but the underlying design principle you
get from these scores so what they're
saying here is you know maybe if we want
better models of the visual hierarchy we
should just optimize for categorization
performance and you know certainly there
are other design principles waiting to
be found to guide our future modeling
efforts now these benchmarks and scores
have been productive for vision you know
but what about everything else you know
and this is where this project comes in
we felt that the time was right uh for
similar efforts with your current models
that Encompass a larger diversity of
tasks s and brain
regions now you know scores and
benchmarks are are really just another
tool in the tool kit here so I I don't
think we can reduce our model goodness
down to a single number but I think
these can be useful things if they lead
us to uh better models of the brain
maybe they allow us to extract General
design principles that are applicable
for many networks or you know maybe even
just shine a spotlight on tasks and data
set that are difficult to model Okay so
here's uh the approach that we're taking
we're collecting a benchmark of many
experimental data sets from areas like
prefrontal cortex lip parietal cortex
and motor cortex um in this project
we're focusing on trying to understand
you know firing rates of neurons in
these different brain areas we're coding
up different models to compare to these
data sets and then we want to know if
the models are on the right track so
we're evaluating the similarity between
the models and data with various
techniques uh then I'll tell you a
little a little bit more about and you
know the goal here is really to extract
General design principles that are
applicable across many brain regions and
tasks or shine a spotlight uh on where a
certain design principles fail and you
know finding these failure points is
also you know useful and this is really
a virtuous cycle where we can loop back
around to improve the benchmarks you
know evaluation metrics and ultimately
the networks that we use to model the
brain okay so let's dive in right
there's a lot of models in neuroscience
and where are we going to start well we
want to model the neurodynamics of
animals performing experimental tasks so
we'd like our models to be able to solve
the same experimental tasks as these
animals so you know this gets it back to
the the beginning here we're going to
use these recurrent neural networks
where the inputs to our model are going
to be time bearing signals representing
experimental stimuli and the outputs are
going to be time bearing signals
representing behavioral
responses and you know let's let's look
at models trained on this reaching task
that we've seen before so as a reminder
there's 27 different reaching conditions
for this task so each color shows data
from one of these reaches that the
monkey made uh the figures at the top
show the inputs and outputs used to
train the models and the figures at the
bottom show the firing rates of neurons
in the brain and in these RNN models so
here are
three different models uh in a couple
different units um and you know we can
sort of see a nice similarity it's it's
this is reassuring that we have this
decent match between single neurons and
single units um you know and that our
models can actually reproduce the the
neurodynamics down to the level of
firing rates but we also want some more
convenient and concrete way of assessing
this match between a model and data you
know a single number that quantifies how
well an entire model matches a neural
data set um and I just want to give you
a taste of one of these methods because
I think it offers a nice intuitive
window into how we might start comparing
multiple neurons with multiple units
from a model and you know I think this
question of model data comparison is
just you know generally interesting
question and we'll all be thinking about
it more as we continue to analyze data
from more and more neurons and brain
regions all right so for starters
imagine these are our two data sets so
data set one contains a single neuron uh
data set two contains a single neuron
and we're comparing the firing rates of
these neurons Ed over time well I think
one of the most intuitive ways of
comparing these two curves is just to
compute the correlation between them you
know so when does one curve rise and
fall um and does it rise at the same
time as the other one um and in this
case the correlation or the similarity
between the two data sets is
0.6 um now let's add a few more neurons
so data set one now has four neurons and
data set two has three neurons you know
how similar are these two data sets so
we're going to borrow the same intuition
we had with the correlation coefficient
we're going to try to identify some
common underlying signal between these
two data sets that rises and falls at
the same time in other words we're going
to try and find linear combinations of
these firing rates that are maximally
correlated and this is called canonical
correlations analysis or just CCA for
short so CCA identifies linear
combinations of these original variables
that are most linearly related in other
words it identifies linear combinations
of the firing rates which we call
canonical components such that the
Pearson correlation coefficient is as
large as possible between these
canonical components so here we can see
the first canonical component for each
data set um and just like we were trying
to find you know they look pretty
correlated so in fact uh they have a
correlation of
0.95 and now we can play the same game
and find a second canonical component
that's uncorrelated from the first and
it's just another linear combination of
the firing rates in these data sets um
and these correlations between canonical
components summarize how similar these
two data sets are for example we can
take the mean of these correlations and
that gives us a single number that
summarize the similarity between data
sets one and two um and as a caveat CCA
you know it's not necessarily the best
similarity measure but it's commonly
used in papers and you know mainly I
just want to give you uh get you
thinking about this problem of comparing
two data
sets Okay so there's a number of uh
different methods um you know I'm not
going to go into them just for the sake
of
time
we we can also kind of Wonder to
ourselves you know why we should prefer
you know one method uh ver versus
another and you know I think the way
that I want to approach this question is
just to say that you know there's been a
lot of uh careful work um
by previous scientists you know Finding
important features in neural data so the
extent that some of these measures uh
agree with the careful work that's
previously been done I'm going to
believe some of these similarity
measures and then if they don't agree
I'm I'm less inclined uh to believe them
and I guess the natural follow-up
question to this then is well if these
scores are always just agreeing with
previous analyses you know what's the
benefit you know why do we need these
scores and I would just say you know I
see uh enough I see a couple different
benefits and one is a practical benefit
it's just easier to screen hundreds of
models by plotting a single number
versus looking at a whole set of more
detailed analysis and then two you know
there are tasks in brain regions where
researchers haven't built up such
detailed intuitions about what's
important but we can still apply these
scores in these cases and if the scores
are good we can feel more confident
about saying you know our models are
doing a good job on this task and brain
region and if the scores are bad we can
say hey let's let's slow down you know
there's something interesting here our
models aren't capturing and now we need
to look closer um and so at least this
is how I feel comfortable approaching
these metrics you know but I'm I'm
certainly at this point open to to other
ideas okay so uh for the sake of time I
think I'm going to uh skip ahead but you
know basically the idea here is that you
can take these metrics um apply them to
models and data and compute similari
scores telling you how similar models
are to the different data and you can
start evaluating uh the models um on on
these using these scores and basically
try to find models um that are more
similar to the data and you know
hopefully improve the models so I'm
going to go here um all the way up to a
set of sort of fun things to do with
these types of models model so this is
really early days in the modeling
efforts um but I I think there's there's
so many different ways that you know we
can improve these models so we can start
to include more realistic inputs you
know remember when I showed you the
inputs for modeling this reaching task
they were little one-dimensional bumps
right but we could actually hook up
these models to the computer screen just
that the similar to the monkey sees and
we could sort of see if that uh improves
these models ability to describe neural
data um we can start Parc slating out
these models to have different brain
regions um we can play with different
games for how we train these models so
maybe these models should be trained on
a single task that the um the human or
other animals trained on or like humans
and other animals maybe these models
should be trained on a whole diversity
of tasks and maybe that's going to lead
to more similarity to neural data
there's also different kinds of learning
rules you know there's all sorts of
things and also the kinds of models um
sort of the the neuron models that we
use in these recurrent neural networks
can also be different um and that maybe
will also influence how well we're able
to explain neural data so I just want to
uh thank my collaborators on this part
of the project uh Nathan muon Megan
Katherine and Robert and sort of say
that you know this is still really I
would say early days um in modeling
effort that incorporate neural networks
but I think there's really exciting
progress towards you know building these
more whole brain models um and you know
really uh coming to some sort of better
understanding of the richness of what
makes us human so you know thank you for
your